peu d'avoir commencé avec le question du
jour on aurait pu parler effectivement
du terrorisme
vous retrouvez d'ailleurs sur le site
des extraits du discours de gérald
darmanin devant la dgsi et qui fait le
point sur l'état de la menace
on pourrait reparler également de la
récidive on reparlera de cette question
là cette semaine
mais la question également qui se pose
en ce moment c'est sur cette
généralisation du masque sur les lieux
de travail c'est la question d'ailleurs
qu'on pose sur le site du figaro est ce
que vous l'approuvez vous est pour
l'instant une large majorité à
l'approuver si vous n'avez pas encore
répondu à la question avant de répondre
je vous propose plusieurs éléments
d'abord cette opinion que l'on a glanés
la semaine dernière dans la rue quand on
a annoncé la généralisation du masque
cette fois ci à paris moi je suis pour
le port du masque
je suis pour l'antique août à jour tout
ce qu'on veut mais dans les endroits que
je trouve que certains endroits
extérieur c'est vraiment inutile on
rajoute de la peur aux gens c'est du
n'importe quoi alors on rajoute de la
peur aux gens c'est l'opinion de cette
dame est ce que c'est le vôtre vous
allez nous le dirons tous les cas ce qui
est vrai c'est que la peur et le
sentiment qui domine quand on évoque la
question du deux lacs au vide puisque là
vous êtes une large majorité si j'en
crois le sondage au look ça pour figaro
et france info qui le large majorité a
exprimé de la peur à l'égard de la
situation sanitaire globale du pays ce
qui est intéressant également c'est que
cette peur suit la courbe des âges plus
on est jeune moins on a peur
plus on avance en âge je n'ose pas dire
quand âgées puisque ça va c'est la
dernière catégorie ses 65 ans et plus à
ce que l'on est âgé de 65 ans est un
autre débat
en tous les cas c'est là que culmine
justement ce sentiment de peur alors
même s'il a plus de 60 ans 1m ne partage
pas cette peur c'est bernard henri lévy
il vient de faire paraître un livre
ce virus qui rend fou et d'ailleurs en
lisant on pourra lire un autre livre
c'est celui qui a publié philippe de
villiers cet été pour le philosophe
la peur est plus dangereuse que la
maladie il y a dit il vous le voyez
notamment dans cette citation plus de
cas mais moins deux morts alors vous
qu'en pensez vous quel est votre avis
c'est la vie que j'ai envie de vous
poser
nicolas quant au début de votre votre
chronique aujourd'hui vous dites il ya
un regain de il ya un regain de vie de
dix neuf et on quand on le quand on vous
lit on a le sentiment que c'est une
vraie menace
oui non mais bien sûr il ya un regain de
cette épidémie et c'est une menace pour
la population c'est aussi une menace
évidemment pour pour l'économie mais
vous savez ces roseaux menace pour la
population et pour l'économie mais est
ce que c'est le co vide la cage vide qui
menacent l'économie ou bien les mesures
que l'on prend pour juguler ou pour
stopper la propagation du corps vide
il va y venir c'est à dire que le la
peur est encore plus contagieuse que là
que vivent 19 sert aux nouvelles dans le
discours du new deal qui avait dit que
la seule chose dont on devait vraiment
avoir peur c'était la peur elle-même
c'est exactement ce qui est en train
d'arriver c'est d'ailleurs pour ça à mon
avis que le la position de bernard henri
lévy mme mans que sa cible c'est que
qu'est ce qu'il faut pour ne pas avoir
peur d'abord il est normal de lutter
contre cette épidémie et de l'apprendre
extrêmement au sérieux mais pour la
prendre pour lutter contre elle il faut
pas succomber à la panique il faut avoir
une stratégie cohérente la stratégie
cohérente elle est parfaitement connue
elle a été testée par les pays qui ont
réussi à avoir des résultats et à la
mettre sous contrôle c'est à dire la
corée du sud taïwan l'allemagne ou la
nouvelle zélande
c'est extrêmement simple il faut tester
tracé isolées et soignées
or la france ne fait aucun des quatre
donc c'est ça le problème
les tests on a qu'à voir le à paris ça
continue à être extrêmement compliqué on
a des filles attendent l'application le
stop qu'ovide c'est un fiasco et un vrai
scandale ça marche absolument pas
personne n'est dessus et on a eu l'idée
française complètement biscornu de
vouloir faire une application sans les
fabricants de portables
évidemment ça ne peut pas marcher il
suffisait d'aller prendre ce qui marche
à l'étranger isolés on isole pas puisque
haut contrairement à beaucoup de pays
si vous êtes testé positif vous n'avez
pas l'obligation de d'être dans un
endroit où on peut contrôler que vous
êtes effectivement et enfin sur les
soins
il ya une montée en puissance de
l'appareil hospitalier mais aujourd'hui
on reste à peu près à 12000 litres et
animations équipe et il y en a 40 milles
en allemagne et à 67 millions dont
correspond portes il ya quatre ans donc
si vous voulez c'est bien ça le problème
c'est que là où bernard lévy henri lévy
se trompe c'est en disant que l'épidémie
n'est pas un problème est que le masque
il est d'ailleurs assez méprisant
vis-à-vis des sociétés asiatiques et je
pense qu'ils se trompent aussi
lourdement là dessus les démocraties
asiatiques ont vraiment montré une
excellente mal ce mec est en revanche il
a raison c'est que l'idéologie de la
peur c'est une arme fatale
d'abord ça n'aille pas lutter contre les
que le l'épidémie mais en revanche ça tu
l'économie et ça tue la démocratie
alors on va on va justement on va y
revenir peut-être sur ce que disait
nicolas sur la tribune de bernard henri
lévy et
ça m'intéresserait de savoir ce que vous
avez pensé à la lecture de cette tribune
est ensuite justement sur sur cette idée
est ce que on a aujourd'hui trop peur
est ce que vous comprenez en tout cas ce
que vous partagez la
cette angoisse qui est largement
exprimée dans sa majorité je vais vous
donner un scoop une fois n'est pas
coutume je suis d'accord avec bernard
orly d'accord aussi avec cela dit
nicolas braises mais bernard henri lévy
dans la tribune parle du masque est
effectivement le masquage peut-être
toutes nos défaillances sur les autres
points si on tombe dans une espèce de
d'absurdité où il faut porter le masque
même en plein air c'est bien parce qu'on
n'est pas prêt sur les autres points qui
sont qui sont stratégiques
donc moi je suis effectivement pour une
politique efficace à nombre de lits
conséquent un nombre de respirateurs
conséquent traçage on peut en discuter à
un moment donné on parlait des fameuses
brigades qui était à mon avis à un monde
totalement inapproprié on a l ont
disparu dans la nature
ces brigades et ensuite effectivement
pour tester isolés on voit qu'on a du
retard sur ce pouvoir après soit le
masque effectivement on a le sentiment
que le gouvernement était temps
défaillances sur les autres points
eh bien il veut faire peur aux citoyens
pour que le virus ne se diffuse pas mais
je crois que c'est pas une politique
offensive et c'est une politique qui va
avoir des procès quoi c'est
effectivement économique et social
peut-être plus terrifiante que le virus
lui-même le vous parlais justement deux
sets de 7 de cette stratégie inquiets la
stratégie de tester deux tracés îles
isolées ce matin et de soigner et de
soigner mais justement testé tracé isolé
ce matin vous dénoncez le recul de la
démocratie pendant l'été
derrière justement les piques du mythe
que vides mais ce que les mesures
sanitaires mêmes qui sont prises dans
les pays où ça marche ne font pas
reculer la démocratie avec les pestes
les traçages avec quand même les
brigades qu'ovide le confinement la
restriction de sortie qu'on a vu
notamment encore cet été dans les ehpad
non mais si on regarde par exemple
on a des idées extrêmement fausses sur
par exemple les applications numériques
qui ont été mises en place en corée du
sud ou à taïwan c'est strictement
encadrée ça n'est pas le gouvernement
on ne peut tracer que les quinze jours
passent et donc la période utile ensuite
non ne peuvent avoir accès aux données
que ceux qui en ont vraiment besoin pour
lutter contre l'épidémie et tout ça est
détruit après donc on a des idées qui
sont extrêmement qui sont extrêmement
fausses et par ailleurs ce qui est vrai
c'est qu'il ya des arbitrages à faire et
je rappelle quand même que ce qui a de
plus attentatoire aux libertés publiques
ça reste le confinement est ce qu on a
vu alors en france on l'a appliqué avec
une brutalité particulière mais en
france du point de vue des libertés
publiques
ça a quand même été un véritable krach y
compris par le fait qu'on n'a pas une
justice la justice est arrêté pendant
trois mois ce qui est quand même quelque
chose de da u récent donc évidemment on
se porte le mieux sans épidémie et sans
les contraintes qui vont avec mais
ensuite il ya des arbitrages à faire
entre des solutions qui sont plus ou
moins négatif est en tout cas ce qu'ont
montré notamment les démocraties
asiatique parce qu'effectivement
singapour hong kong c'est autre chose
mais corée du sud et taiwan ont montré
qu'on pouvait être efficace sur le plan
sanitaire et sur le plan économique avec
des atteintes limité aux libertés et aux
libertés publiques et avec un état de
droit qui continuent à fonctionner je
vous rappelle qu'en corée du sud
il ya eu des élections législatives le
15 avril des élections générales qui se
sont parfaitement bien déroulée et qui
ont été organisées dans un alors que
c'est un des rares pays où sa housse a
eu lieu
donc ça montre que c'est que ça montre
que c'est que c'est possible et il faut
pas avoir l'idée de même qui est absurde
expliqué que la 5g être anti écologique
et croire que parce qu'on a une
application numérique et les teintes
attentatoires aux libertés non c'est pas
vrai il ça dépend de la manière dont on
la met dans toi la met en oeuvre
maintenant une épidémie c'est vrai que
ce qu'on a re découvert c'est que bien
sûr l'épidémie par les contraintes
qu'elle impose à la population sur parce
qu'on a des contraintes effectivement
bien que deux voix et bien sûr que
l'épidémie bouscule la démocratie
beaucoup plus qu'un régime total que
capitaliste comme le régime chinois
oui non mais parce que là où vous n'avez
pas vraiment répondu c'est qu'on voit
bien que les les démocraties libérales
ont été mises face à l'heure à leurs
contradictions et que l on était aussi
liberticide que les régimes dits populis
alors je mets pas la chine
l'as d'or qui est pour moi un régime
totalitaire dit même là aussi qu'il ya
un régime autoritaire mais c'est
difficile ensuite de donner des leçons à
viktor orban et donald trump iliad est
un des aspects de la tribune de garn
henri lévy qui était intéressante c'est
que s'interroge quand même sur le le
monde d'après ce qu'on va vers une
démocratie gouverné par une technocratie
de plus en plus tatillonne qui
multiplierait des règles j'ai
l'impression que le masque on nous dit
va falloir apprendre à vivre avec le
masque en toutes circonstances comme ça
avec les règles qui sont rabâcher matin
midi et soir
ça donne aussi l'idée d'une forme de
contrôle social que moi je trouve
inquiétante ajoutez à cela le triomphe
de l'économie numérique dégâts etc
je pense que le monde d'après y compris
dans les démocraties libérales est
inquiétante
réponse du tac ville
un nicolas baverez sur l'échec de
facilité non mais ça c'est une idée
générale qui est une idée fausse parce
que quand on regarde quels sont pour les
démocraties
d'abord dans celles qui ont les
résultats les plus mauvais il ya celles
qui sont dirigés par des populistes
donald trump aux etats unis c'est un
désastre sanitaire est un désastre
économique ball sonar ou au brésil
johnson
au royaume uni ce sont trois
catastrophes sanitaires trois
catastrophes économiques le royaume uni
c'est le pays développés qui a le plus
fort recul du du pub au deuxième
trimestre alors il yal inverse
on trouve dans les pays qui ont les
mieux réagi il se trouve contre eux on
trouve des démocraties
l'allemagne est une vraie démocratie
l'état de droit a été préservé la
nouvelle-zélande est une vraie
démocratie et on oublie toujours c'est
ce que je rappelais la corée du sud et
taiwan ce sont des vraies démocraties
les pays d'europe du nord ce sont aussi
plutôt bien sorti d'affaires d'ailleurs
avec des stratégies très différentes y
compris la suède qui est qui est
discutée mais qui pour l'instant il faut
toujours être prudent mais en réalité la
stratégie de nombreux films en de la
suède ne donne pas de si mauvais
résultat donc c'est pour ça que de dire
que c'est la démocratie libérale qui a
fait je pense que c'est faux parce que
certaines démocraties ont beaucoup
souffert la france en fait
malheureusement partie mais d'autres ont
été bien bien supérieur à la plupart des
la plupart des autres pays donc en fait
la vérité c'est que les épidémies c'est
comme les grandes crises économiques
c'est à dire que c'est un espèce de tami
et que ça fait un tri impitoyable entre
les pays qui ont des institutions fortes
d économie qui fonctionne bien et des
dirigeants qui sont imaginatifs
responsable et puis des états qui sont à
la fois efficace et agile et puis les
autres et donc aujourd'hui c'est vrai
que dans les dents les gagnants on
trouvera on trouvera des démocraties on
trouvera aussi des régimes autoritaires
dans les perdants on aura les eaux aussi
un ailier rares chi des pays va être
considérablement modifié qui singer a
raison de dire que l'ordre et
l'équilibré du monde soir à modifier
parce qu'on est d'accord sur le constat
qu'il ya eu des mots des mots d
autoritaire qui ont bien réagi des
démocraties qui ont bien réagi et vi et
vice versa moi je crois que l'ordre du
monde va être bouleversée mais aussi
parce qu'on a vu les limites de
de la mondialisation quand vous avez dit
on va y revenir je sors sur les limites
de la mondialisation pardon je veux pas
vous juste sur deux deux choses d'abord
je salue nos internautes qui nous
rejoignent notamment bernard et fred
bernard qui nous dit arrêtons de crâne
cette épidémie pourquoi ne pas laisser
faire la sélection naturelle et un écrou
d'un écroulement de la démocratie de
l'économie serait beaucoup plus grave
alors ça paraît choquant peut-être chose
que disent que ce que peut dire bernard
notamment sur sa liste l idée de
séduction naturelle mais un autre côté
il y a quelque chose en tous les cas un
curseur qui a été non mais là où il
attend si vous voulez c'est que vous
avez le cas du brésil les gens ont
soi-disant a opté pour la défense de
l'économie sans rien faire sur le
sanitaire et du coup vous avez la double
catastrophe
donc c'est pas vrai si on ne le suit à 2
on ne peut pas non mais les suédois il y
avait une stratégie de lutte contre
l'épidémie simplement elle passait pas
par le confinement est il donc si vous
voulez c'est à dire qu'on laisse
simplement faire l'épidémie pour
protéger l'économie
c'est faux d'ailleurs ça révèle la vraie
nature de ball football sauna au moi je
l'indiquais dans mon livre ne classe pas
parmi les populistes d'ailleurs je pense
que le populaire c'est un phénomène
concerne la démocratie occidentale le
brésil pays d'amérique latine est encore
une situation différente mais boys now
est un libéral autoritaire bien plus
qu'un gain populace qui pratiquent la
politique de du laisser-faire des
ministres qui viennent de l'école de
chicago et effectivement on voit le
résultat quand on place l'économie est
avant tout et là je suis d'accord avec
ce qui a été dit il faut trouver le bon
curseur entre les deux c'est l'hystérie
totale on se croirait dans un film de
science fiction c'est ce que nous a dit
fred sur un tweeter chez lui au lam qui
nous rejoint également bienvenus de
retour donc sur les forums du figaro on
attend vos questions on attend vos
réactions une toute dernière action sur
cette généralisation du masque sur les
lieux de travail votre point de vue
nicolas je rejoins ce qui a été dit et
c'est le penalty de compensation
c'est à dire que parce que le président
de la république et son gouvernement de
l'époque sont passés complètement à côté
de la sphère du masque parce qu'on en
avait pas en expliquer ça ne servait à
rien ce qui était évidemment faux et
absurde
donc on court après ça depuis le début
ne va pas la même chose et est donc non
parce que le le test ça on sait que
c'est indispensable et que le on en est
qu'aujourd'hui ans en région parisienne
notamment on a une capacité de tests qui
est insuffisante
il ya mais c'est vrai que la généraliser
est très longue avec la sueur les
traçages qui peuvent être issus des
tests pour l'instant on ne peut pas
faire de traçage puisque le les soi
disantes les brigades et brigades du
congo là on pourrait appeler ça les
bribes et les brigades du point gaulin
on allait les brigades du tigre avec tes
manceau maintenant on a les brigades du
congo la wii n'est pas pour moi monsieur
vers en est avec ces brigades du pont
ango la ccc risible sont faibles et donc
ça vous fait pas peur
mc on n'est pas que les morceaux dans
les tranchées approuvez vous cette gamme
là je vous pose la question c'est la
question qu'on pose sur le site du
figaro approuvez-vous la généralisation
du masque sur les lieux de travail et
s'ils ont donc à laquelle vous pourrez
répondre et pour l'instant vous êtes une
un char majorité à répondre oui et sur
twitter vous poser une autre question
estimez-vous que l'on cède à la panique
dans la lutte contre la copie de disney
fait là aussi vous répondez oui à 57 % à
chaque fois ce sont les questions sont
pas des sondages